one tuesday morning
a developer
sits down at their desk
and they opened up their laptop
and they glanced at some monitoring
graphs and they're like
huh
is that a little blip i can't quite tell
could that possibly be related to the
feature i deployed yesterday
um so they open up a tab and they go to
their log aggregator and they type in a
query to maybe find some relevant
entries
and
they hit start
and then they get up and they go to the
kitchen for more coffee
that's it that's the end of the story
they never get back to that tab it's
gone it's out of their heads
thank you for coming
i'm jessica care
and
justatron on twitter
and this talk uh it's got ian wilkes's
name on it too because it's his story um
but he's still in california he didn't
want to travel so he is right now in the
chat channel
um in the strange loop slack and also
he's like watching us
virtually
so go there and ask him questions
ian is the database engineer
on this project he's been at honeycomb
for several years and he implemented the
story that i'm telling today
i'm a developer advocate
um and i started honeycomb two months
ago
so this is very exciting and new to me
and
i think it's great
i'm up here to tell you how we use
aws lambda to do something very
interesting
and also
how very interesting it is to use aws
lambda
first of all i want to tell you how we
use it but to tell you how we use lambda
i have to tell you what we use it for
and that's our custom data store which
is called retriever not this retriever
that's liz fong jones's cute dog
but our custom data store is pretty
interesting so interesting that four
years ago right in this hotel
at strange loop sam stokes gave a talk
about
the data store itself and i'll need to
repeat part of that talk for you except
it'll only be
about four minutes of it
but before i do that i have to tell you
what retriever is for why did we
implement this custom data store and
that's because honeycomb has very
specific strengths and therefore
specific needs
four years ago at strange loop
one of our founders charity majors gave
a talk about what makes honeycomb so
interesting and two years ago our other
founder christine yen who's now the ceo
also talked about what honeycomb can do
so i'll give you that information but in
five minutes
okay what is honeycomb for it's for
observability and by observability i
mean being able to find out what's going
on in your system in production
and to find surprises to find things you
didn't know what you were looking for
so it kind of turns monitoring on its
head because monitoring is like okay
tell me what you want to watch for which
of course is everything that's burned
you in the past every graph in your
dashboard is scar tissue
but monitoring is really good at
counting all that stuff up so that the
graphs are fast
honeycomb
says
okay tell me what you want to look at
right now
and i'll make all of it fast
you don't have to know ahead of time
what you're going to need to counter
aggregate and you're also going to be
able to get to the raw data let me show
you what that's like
so okay the other day i sat down
uh to find out
how long our lamb just run i was like
okay how long does a lambda invocation
take at honeycomb and so
is it gonna play yeah yeah so i was like
okay i gotta find the right spans
to do that let's see i i'll count
something i know the service name is
lambda for these guys um yep there's
some now what is the name of the span
that i need i'll have it group by name
and then it's gonna it's gonna show me
all the names
and so i'll scroll down to the list and
aha invoke that's the one i want all the
invokes show me only those
okay
yep there they are just the invocations
now that i have them i can say okay
what's their median run time so i got a
p50 of the duration and i can get a
graph of that
okay well i look at it i'm like why why
is this so spiky it's like sometimes
they're half a second sometimes they're
a second and a half
i'm gonna like
try to investigate a little further and
find out why that is
so i zoom into this
extra spiky section
and i'm like huh
uh i would like to like ask what's
different about these really long ones
so first i'll get a heat map the heat
map shows like all of the traces and how
slow they were at the same time
but more importantly it lets me click on
bubble up
and then i can like draw a box around
the area that's like got an extra high
median
response time
and say what's different about these
and we've run some like super basic
statistical analysis this is not ai
unless you really need us to sell you
that in which case
i'll it's still not ai
um
it's just saying okay look this section
has a lot of this one trace id and i'm
like that's interesting okay i want to
find out about that trace id so that
represents one particular query coming
in from our web interface from the
product
uh and i know i can get the the query
spec
because we have like all the raw event
data available i'm like okay which span
in this trace would have the query spec
on it so i'll look where query spec
exists
and um
it's like okay well there's these and
retriever client fetch
your client fetch that looks good that's
like the top level of the query so as it
comes in
to the database
so i'll get just that one and then i'll
go look at the raw data now i can see
everything that came in oh there's the
query spec
uh yeah that looks hard
sure
i mean
i'm still new so i don't know how to
read that yet
but it's plenty for me to say hey ian
what's going on with this
and and also i can like send in the
links or i can post it in slack to all
of these queries that i ran
so that he can see what i was looking at
and we can talk about it
so honeycomb is letting me ask these
questions and a different question and
then a different question and also it
helps us talk about them and spread
knowledge throughout
the engineering team
overall honeycomb
enables rapid fire interactive debugging
of what the heck is going on in
production
and
interactive is important there
because if i have to go get another cup
of coffee that is not interactive
i can take a sip of my coffee i'm okay
if i have to like take a sip
and then it's there that's that's just
peaceful
um
but going to get a cup of coffee is not
okay so we need our data store to
respond very quickly to any query over
any field and any combination of fields
no indexing
no pre-aggregation we only store the raw
data and we do all the plusing
and the other monoids
at runtime after you send us the query
okay how does retriever do that well at
very high level there's some events that
come in from your applications or your
ci systems and retrieve your source them
all
and then later
you the developer
interact with the ui and send queries
and retriever sends you the results and
then you send to more queries and blah
blah
okay but that's very high level zooming
in a little bit on the retriever part
events come in on kafka
kafka partitions them
on each partition there's a retriever
actually two retrievers we run them in
pairs for redundancy
um and so the the retriever reads all of
the events coming in on kafka and stores
them in local disk
and then when the query comes in it
comes into one retriever that retriever
uh fans out the query to all the
retrievers that have data on their local
disk for this particular data set
and they all access their local disk add
a bunch of stuff up send it back to the
original retriever who
consolidates those monoids and sends the
total results back to the ui
cool we use nvme local disk which is not
too expensive and very fast
um ssds are just fast these days it's
pretty sweet
right
so
that's fine and then oh so that's trick
number one distributed data store trick
number two
is distributed column store
uh sam talked a lot about this so we're
not just dumping those events in one
file on local disk we're more clever
about it than that
we divide them up into a column into
every every field in the event is a
column
everything has a timestamp but other
than that it could be anything or
nothing there's no predefined schemas
here
so we put each column in a separate
field we add an arbitrary id so that we
can hook the different records together
and events tend to be sparse in
honeycomb because your ci tests might
have
a bunch of fields about testing and
something else will have completely
different fields and you can add new
fields at any time so these uh the
column store means these files don't all
have to be the same length we can save
space and more importantly save reads
that way
the file per column helps us a lot
especially because when the query comes
in we only read the files for the
columns in the query
so we'll always read the time stamp file
but then we'll read whatever columns you
filtered on and whatever columns you
want to add up but that's it
when you do go ask for the raw data for
like the full span then we'll access
every one but that's fine that's smaller
right so column store that's trick
number two trick number three
is we can't let these files grow to grow
forever we have to segment them somehow
we segment them
uh well we segment them as they come in
at some point we're just like oh that
segment's done so they're really
segmented by arrival
but we store
timestamp so i lied about no indexes
there's really exactly one index it's
the timestamp because on all of these
graphs that we're showing the x-axis is
timestamp
every query comes with a time range
this is the one thing we do index on
um so every
million rows or 12 hours or gigabyte
we we chop that segment off
store in the database what its time
stamp range is and start with the next
one now
these are
kafka guarantees that the events are in
the order that they were
given to kafka
but different applications in your
infrastructure might be sending events
at different rates so
they're not like perfectly
um disjoint on time stamp but that's
okay they overlap we know which segments
overlap it's fine
so in the end we wind up with each
retriever has a but per data set
which is kind of like a table
it has a bunch of segments and it knows
what time stamps each of those are and
that means when the query comes in
retriever knows which segments it has to
read and it has to read the entire
segment
but only for the ones that contains
anything in that time range
this is fine
so that's great this this works this is
the the state of retrieval as of sam's
talk four years ago
it does dynamic aggregation of any
fields
across any time range
and
and it's fast now
it's carefully suited to our problem and
it's continually optimized
and the other people on his team are
always always making it faster
and then we give it more to do and then
they make it faster and then we give it
more to do
for instance
at some point
we get bigger customers and bigger
customers have higher volume
of event data and as of four years ago
we were selling like gigabytes how much
of your data will we store on these
local disks at a time
and and that the customers are like
gigabytes
tr try terabytes let's start there
um and so this these local disks start
to look pretty small
and there's there's only so big a disc
you can get on one ec2 instance and
when if you start adding ec2 instances
that has other problems and it's
complicated and expensive so
all right local disk is too small
because as these events come in i mean
we've got a limit of how much data we'll
keep for each customer
so as soon as
as soon as they fill that up we start
deleting the oldest stuff so now we've
got these segments filling up however
many gigabytes um and you know we've got
10 minutes of data and then we're
throwing it away
that's that's not enough 10 minutes is
not enough okay so we need clearly more
data and when you have more data what do
you do
you put it in s3 of course
which holds all the data in the world
and more than you have ever created okay
so yeah we're like s3s the whole world
we'll just supplement our local disk
with s3
okay so now each retriever is
responsible for instead of just deleting
the data as it runs out of space moving
it to s3 and so now
we can keep all of the data for 60 days
and on query the retriever
for each each of the segments that it's
in charge of it still knows which time
stamps go to which segments and so it'll
go retrieve what it needs and add it all
up
and now customers can run queries over
60 days worth of data
oh no
they're running queries over 60 days
worth of data
that's so much data
and our our poor retrievers are like
they're adding and adding and adding it
and here's the thing to know about
this
particular problem
for us in our circumstances the limiting
factor here is not io it's not network
it's cpu
because as we're reading each file each
record in each file we're making a
decision like if it's a filter column
it's like keep it skip it keep it skip
it keep it skip it or if it's if it's
one of the aggregation columns we're
like okay build the q digest for the p50
or whatever it is um so we're constantly
aggregating and deciding and it's
compute that limits how fast we can read
the data
so we wind up being cpu bound which
means however much
we've only got like 8 cpus per retriever
that's what we're stuck with so however
much data we have to read however wide
that time frame is
that's how much longer the query is
going to be
so you get like this linear
roughly
extension in response time with respect
to how long you're querying over and how
big your data set is
and that's not cool
because we're way past sip range now
you go get a cup and you come back we
had to extend our
query timeout to an hour
that's like roast the beans and grind
them and make yourself a very fresh pot
this is not interactive
okay so that's not okay we need this
line to be very sublinear
uh we need response time
um to you know
some queries are just harder than others
and bigger than others and if if the
extreme ones take a minute we're gonna
live not four minutes
but a few of them will take one but that
is the outside so instead of scaling our
response time with the amount of data
we're reading we want to scale our
compute
and we need to scale that compute really
fast because again we want to respond
within a minute
so i mean normally when you want to
scale over
scale compute you start up more ec2
instances
well right now starting up an ec2
instance takes us like five minutes
ask me again in a few weeks when we're
on kubernetes it might be different but
it's not going to be less than 30
seconds
that's not going to get us to those sip
level response times that we're aiming
for so starting up new instances is
right out i mean we could keep instances
running
but we're not made of money that
it's ridiculous the queries that come in
for us
uh here's a frequency
this is a this is the count of lambda
invocations over 24 hours
so you can see how high and thin these
peaks are
if we've ran enough ec2 instances to
have the cpu for this peak we'd be
running thousands and doing nothing with
them
99 of the day
so that's ridiculously expensive that's
out so we need more compute and we need
it fast
all right so whoops that was backwards
okay
so lambda our retrievers have written in
go
so we spun out this little go function
and put it in the cloud
and now each retriever it knows how many
segments in s3 that it's responsible for
aggregating so it spins up a lambda per
eight or in this picture four of them
and says you do it
and the lambda being i mean practically
next door to s3
um reads those files
and does that aggregation and ships it
back to its retriever which ships it
back to the retriever that got the query
which ships it back to the ui
aggregating aggregating aggregating
really fast
uh this works so each retriever now
instead of being responsible for
thousands of segments is responsible for
thousands divided by eight of lambdas
to aggregate
and it worked here's a very rough graph
of a couple samples of our average query
time based on the number of segments
it's retrieving from s3 the important
part it is sublinear
we are scaling compute
instead of response time
so this is what we use lambda for
we use it for on-demand compute
and we think that's pretty cool
it's it's working for us
we observe a 50 millisecond median
startup time now sometimes that's faster
if it's a hot start it might be 10
milliseconds if it's a cold start it
might be 300 it's fine it's well within
a sip where it's fine
um ours take about one point 1.5 seconds
at the 90th percentile but of course
that's not an aws stat that's entirely
what we do in our lambdas
that's that's our function
but the last stat here is very much an
aws stat this is calculated based on
sticker prices
um lambda is about three to four times
as expensive as ec2
measured in cpu second
so
so we're paying for compute that's our
limitation that's the price comparison
we're making
and three to four times as expensive
might sound like a lot until you realize
we're running it like a hundredth of the
time and we're only paying what we're
using
so that's a win
of course
there's caveats around all of these
so let's talk about some of the things
that we've learned
at in this process of using lambda in
our database
and like if you're thinking wow this is
cool i bet i could do this too
well here's some stuff to think about
um lambda scales okay lambda scales
very quickly
until it stops
so as with everything in aws there's a
limit this one's called the burst
concurrency limit
and uh you startup land ups you start up
lambdas you get to
in some regions in three thousand in
some regions it's one thousand you get
to this limit
and you start getting http 429 rate
limited
dang it okay now here's the thing
we're using this as burst compute aws
doesn't sell it that way you know they
sell it it's like here's your magic
website back end that you didn't have to
start a server
i don't mind starting servers i just
want more computers please
uh yeah so so their
mechanism for increasing this burst
concurrency limit is that if you have
sustained load if you're running a sale
on your retail site and people are
slamming it then after a minute of
sustained load it'll be like oh i will
boost your concurrency limit by 500.
and now you have 3500 lambdas i and then
another minute and it'll give you
another 500 up to some top limit after
which it stops and above that is all 429
land
this doesn't help us because our load
looks like this
this is completely irrelevant
now aws if you send them a support
ticket is very happy to bump your top
level concurrency limit
i don't care i need them to bump this
one
um yeah so that that's a limitation what
can we do about this
uh we could run more cpus for lambda
that'll help us
uh since it's per lambda invocation and
what aws wants us to do is to pay them
for uh provisioned lambdas so that
they're running all the time and we just
pay less for the cpu that we're not
getting
that doesn't help the whole point is we
need these about like 1 100 of the time
and we don't know we need them until we
need them we don't know we need them
until that query comes in
so no we're not running provisioned
lambdas
um
at some point when we when we
hit the limit
they just have to wait
and and they have to wait meaning
whenever you get a 429 you need to retry
and here's another thing
that we ran well we noticed eventually
that the sdk for go the default timeout
is like a minute
this is not helpful
so no we need to retry more aggressively
than that
we discovered this and we learned about
all these details of course using
honeycomb as we do
and this used to be harder but right now
it's it's easy because we have this
concurrency operator so it's now trivial
to say hey
how many lambda invocation spans are
running right now and it gives me this
nice graph
or we're running at any given what's the
granularity there minute over the last
24 hours
uh this concurrency operator was
released to the public last thursday so
that i could mention it to you today and
now you can use it
yay
yeah so lambda scales within limits the
lessons here are
everything in aws has a limit study them
read this page this that's linked very
carefully
i don't use the default retry parameters
always define your timeouts and your
retries and define them for your use
case
not whatever the heck somebody hard
coded
and observability helps
next
uh median or the median start time so of
course the startup time is not always 50
milliseconds it might be 10 for hot and
300 for cold
um oh here's a cool thing i think this
is fun so the
there's the lambda invocations which is
when we call the functions and it does
stuff but there's also the lambda
instances that those those indications
execute in and we can trace those too so
i just think this is fun to look at a
trace of a lambda instance at the top
there's one little main which is 10
milliseconds which is a slow one they're
mostly microseconds but then it's like
run sleep run sleep run sleep run sleep
and all the all the wider spans here the
long ones are sleeps
now here's the thing about those lambda
sleeps this is not a restful sleep from
which it wakes up refreshed
as soon as that lambda returns its data
it's like here i got a return for you
and it's just stuck and it's completely
frozen and it is not garbage collecting
and it is not doing the cleanup you wish
it could do after it responds to that
request when the next request comes in
okay then it can do its cleanup
so so that like hot start time
yeah it still might be recovering from
the previous request
that cpu time you're not paying for
you're not getting any of it
so that's a consideration that the
sleeps are more like carbon freeze
and i think this is cool so like that
you can compare the concurrency of the
invocations to the instances
so aws is
running
running
sleeping
um
a lot more of our lambda functions than
it's actively using you can see the
width of that graph there i just think
that's a cool graph
all right lambda scales up our compute
oh and
90 of them return within 1.5 seconds
uh
and that's the 1.5 seconds is ours but
there's some things to know about
lambdas for turning uh first of all we
noticed
that while we can get like
a p90 of 1.5 seconds if i look at the
heat map of all the lambdas returning
there's like
there's like this oh there it is right
along here
oh i can't do that straight
um this is like the 32nd line and
there's a lot of traces that
took 30 seconds
right at 30 seconds which turns out to
be the s3 timeout so when you're talking
to s3 it's like 99.9
successful
which is squat when you're running tens
of thousands of them
so failure is totally normal
retries are totally normal
again change your parameters because it
turns out the go sdk by default will
retry for five minutes
no we don't care let it go sdk
so you gotta you gotta watch that
um the other limitation on them
returning is that when they return they
can return six megabytes
this is a heat map of our returns and
the fonts really small but trust me
sometimes we return 200 megabytes of
aggregated data because if you group by
a bunch of fields you're going to return
a whole bunch of groups and that's a lot
of aggregates and it might be 200
megabytes from a single invocation
uh so yeah put that in s3
and send a link um we love s3
s3 holds everything
oh but another thing we did learn was
when you put it in s3 yes compress it no
don't g-zip it
because gzip is an ancient compression
algorithm
that is not the best for anything it's
like fatter and slower than modern
compression algorithms so if you control
both ends of that compression and
decompression please choose a more
modern one
that gave us a big speed up when we
figured that out
also on the way in to your lambdas
you've got there's some limit to how to
the size of course
uh but we didn't notice that what we did
notice
is this is a web backend right so you
gotta send it json
and there's like some aws json cop
that's watching the requests go toward
the lambda and being like no you don't
look like json rejected
uh carly braces okay i we don't know
exactly like what qualifies this json to
this cop because json's kind of a it's a
little fuzzy it's not like checking the
number formats or anything but speaking
of number formats json just no no
you know
store the data in s3 in a format you
control and send a link
when you're using lambda for compute
so a lot of the same things
again study your limits change the retry
parameters
you need observability for this
because it it it's so opaque lambda is
so opaque compared to running on your
own server i mean what is serverless it
means you don't have to care about the
server it means you don't get to know
anything about the server and you have
to like not control the server
earlier today
patrick flores said that works on my
machine doesn't cut it anymore in
distributed systems
there is one run time it is one global
run time and that is it
and that's terrifying
but with lambda it's really true
and so observability makes a big
difference here in figuring out what the
heck is going on
finally cost of course cost is a
consideration because
the positive is you're not paying for it
when you're not using it but the
negative is well what if you suddenly
use it
and how much of it do you use
um in honeycomb we have a trigger that
lets us know if any single customer has
just cost us more than 300 a day in
lambda alone
and when that happens we go look at the
queries that were run and we go
find that person
who wrote a script that imitates the
browser
to repeat a 60-day query every minute or
two
and then we talk to them um because
because um i mean something like this we
have to react to how our customers use
it and sometimes that's helping them use
it sometimes that's like
caching things for the for the api not
for the browser not for not for the
interactive human part but for the api
um we have to react to that all right so
functions have a mysterious amount of
cost
again you have to have your own ways of
monitoring that
um oh oh but speaking of cost maybe they
just got cheaper so last wednesday three
days ago aws released lambda on graviton
2 which is like an arm processor instead
of amd
and they say it's like
they say it's 19
faster faster is cheaper and 20 percent
lower cost which is also cheaper
so
if if this is true then we're going to
get a big boost we already run retriever
on graviton 2 and ec2 so this should
work fine
all right so we already did an
experiment
um we we put in a feature flag and we
started shipping half of our lambda
invocations to graviton 2 in half to the
usual amd processors
the results are
well
the results
these graphs are saying
that the the p50 the median is about 20
slower on the graviton 2
and the p99 is like twice as slow
um so 20 slower 20 cheaper that evens
out so it's costing us the same amount
um except that the extremes are worse
the the slow cases are extra slow so
that's not a win
so last night we flipped the feature
flag and launched darkly to say okay
99.1
we'll keep a few running on arm to
continue the experiment but
most of our customers are going to get
the slightly more predictable response
time from amd
so so that's
lambda is also constantly improving this
is good
final summary slide
again the limits know them
deal with them
and the retry parameters fix them we
haven't talked about deployment
uh
well use versions
and make sure you have feature flags so
you can roll it back really fast when
you observe a problem in production
it's not trivial and then there's
testing
yeah that doesn't work on your box we we
stubbed out the lambdas for for our own
internal testing
and then we see what happens in
production
so yeah observability is a big deal in
this this particular space
but the good news is this works
uh we we are succeeding we are
succeeding so well at scaling up our
compute that we're starting to find
network constraints
and like the aggregating retrievers are
like they're becoming the bottleneck and
and how much they can read so this is
good news
because optimization is all about
finding new bottlenecks as fast as we
can
and all of this is in the name
of preserving our one most precious
resource
which is
developer attention
so thank you all for your attention now
and
oh gosh
i have okay i have five minutes for
questions
um in the room but
ian is in slack which i don't have the
slack up because i wisely did not
connect my computer to the internet
um and uh yeah
find us on slack oh oh next slide jess
honeycomb.io we have a blog with a lot
of the stuff about how we've made
retriever faster over the years
you cannot find ian on twitter because
he exists in real life only
that's how we get so much done
[Music]
but you can follow me on twitter and liz
fong jones who's our other developer
advocate and has a pretty dog
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you